she was a voice of voiceless people she
always raised her voice for the rights
of the minorities in Pakistan
she raised voice for the rights of the
women in Pakistan she was a big
supporter of freedom of expression
it is safe to say that this was in
reaction to in response to the latest
event which was for the unsilent single
Rajasthan as part of the unsilent sequel
Rajasthan campaign
vehicles crying we had to hide me Oh
Barbara helicopters are today in droves
it's critical in in any city but
especially a city that has that faces so
much conflict to have community spaces
where people can get together along
shared interests basically what Sabine
did was to have a place beautiful place
for dialogue and interaction for music
for culture for arts and it will remain
there it's not going away I think it
sort of debilitates a lot of us her
murder
it hurts us and it also challenges our
collective voice
I see a small ray of hope up after the
murder of Sabine my move because this
time I see some reaction and there is
protest today not only in Islamabad but
also in Karachi and the hall so I think
that this is the time to stand up and
raise a strong voice for justice